ارتفاع متسارع في درجات حراره المحيطات
يؤرق العلماء ويزيد المخاوف من تاثير على
الاحتباس الحراري
تحذيرات اطلقتها الامم المتحده ترجح تشكل
ظاهره المناخيه هذا العام ما قد يدفع
درجات الحراره الى معدلات قياسيه جديده
اما المنظمه العالميه للارصاد الجويه
فتوقعت تشكل الظاهره بحلول نهايه يوليو
بنسبه 60% وبحلول نهايه سبتمبر بنسبه 80%
النينيو ظاهره مناخيه طبيعيه تحدث في
المتوسط كل سنتين الى سبع سنوات وتستمر
عاده من تسعه الى 12 شهرا وترتبط عموما
بارتفاع درجات الحراره وزياده الجفاف في
بعض انحاء العالم وبامطار غزيره في مناطق
اخرى ظاهره المينيو حدثت اخر مره في 2018
واتاحتت المجال لحلقه طويله من ظاهره
الينيا التي تسبب اثارا عكسيه خصوصا درجات
الحراره لهذه الظاهره المناخيه عواقب
وخيمه وتعتمد اثارها جزئيا على التوقيت
حيث تهدد النينيو الحياه البحريه بالدرجه
الاولى لان الاسماك لا تستطيع مقاومتها
ومقاومه درجات الحراره المرتفعه اما
تاثيره على البشر فلا يقل ضررا حيث يمكن
ان تسبب الاعاصير وسط المحيط الهادئ وشرقه
كارثه تضرب السواحل فيما تتسبب بالجفاف في
جزء اخر من الارض ما يهدد مصادر الغذاء
العالمي المهدده اصلا بفعل الجفاف وتغير
المناخ
شده ظاهره الينينو او مدتها لا يمكن
توقعها فموجتها الاخيره اعتبرت ضعيفه
مقارنه بالتي حدثت بين عامي 2014
وكانت لها عواقب وخيمه اياد حمود العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات